l'opinion publique ne recule pas non
elle exige le retrait de ce projet mais
plutôt que d'entendre la raison comme
l'on fait certains de vos prédécesseurs
vous vous entêtez sans téter c'est
mettre en danger la cohésion sociale
c'est fracturé c'est jeter le trouble
les seules responsables de la situation
actuelle du blocage annoncé c'est le
gouvernement c'est Monsieur Macron et
demain ce sera peut-être vous mesdames
et messieurs de la majorité sénatoriale
j'évoquais d'entrer le préambule de 46
qui de mon propos le confirme vous
violez la Constitution et vous faites
planer une menace contre le régime même
de retraite en prenant la capitalisation
qui est contraire à l'idée fondamentale
selon laquelle c'est la nation qui
assure les retraites et non pas les
marchés financiers
malgré tout cela
malgré tout cela si si monsieur le
ministre nous savons un peu nous savons
un peu malgré tout cela
Emmanuel Macron persiste et veut une
adoption rapide de ce projet porte en
réforme des retraites il a inscrit cette
dernière donc dans un projet de loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale réservée comme son nom l'indique
à des textes purement financiers
l'avantage donc c'est la limitation du
temps de débat 50 jours en tout 20 jours
pour l'assemblée qu'un jour pour le
Sénat un texte non voté par une
assemblée et donc transmis à l'autre
assemblée et même en cas de non votes de
la seconde une CMP composée de 14
parlementaires et convoqué et peut
valider le texte l'amender et le
réécrire et en cas d'échec de la CMP le
gouvernement peut légiférer par
ordonnance ainsi un projet d'une
importance politique et sociale
considérable peut-être un jour promulgué
sans avoir été examiné jusqu'à son terme
par une des deux assemblées voir les
deux évidemment pour le gouvernement et
maintenant la majorité sénatoriale il
existe une solution
ne débattons pas ou à peine monsieur le
Président du Sénat mes chers collègues
comment avez-vous pu accepter de
délibérer d'un texte qui n'a pas été
soumis au vote de l'Assemblée nationale
je le rappelle les députés sont élus au
suffrage universel direct
l'accepter
l'accepter participe l'accepter
participe au coup de force engagé par le
président de la République contre les
institutions pour imposer cette réforme
massivement rejetée
[Musique]